son you have to transfer it over alright
I don't want you when you put it when
you're hot you're not hot right now well
I will just signal you when you're done
we're gonna have to uh Passover's I need
that report it we're gonna get you
there's gonna be another night
their own name mine
this is the Houseman
so you could transfer this one awesome
this is for the audio that's where the
recording yeah they're mostly on our
YouTube channel like I need you to lay
down a little teacher
the slide caught in my half-hour I don't
know if we can put the slides okay we'll
see
oh you don't get that you'll give us now
this one you're not gonna do this I'll
come check on you to make sure it's on
okay
and this is the Britney Spears link
alex has to get like that straight from
my ear yeah it doesn't go in the year it
goes around like that my ear is too big
yeah
I think alex is actually probably
capable of speaking without a microphone
that means tell Alex
apparently there's only one wave - this
is for recording and this is for and
apparently they only
new year resolution ago and this would
be more social
- VMware
hey how are you doing
I saw junk I just left
and the plaster I know I saw something
on LinkedIn that has a new job
are you moving - are you moving with him
that's true
some awkward silence
yeah
so you know that after
oh we're both kind of like this
I want to see all right or yes yeah seat
next to you raise your hand
and over there all right hold it you
know all you want a seat back there
Tuesday's here there's two over here is
one where they're over there we actually
want to real see they are able to do her
often go for it
so thinking we're getting here our first
meetup of the year the very first
question we always have to hire who's
looking to hire somebody first
so that's work you want to find more
than a dozen page that's not something
like a bar it's posted on there it's
also we've drawn this last channel we
have the spot Council to meet up it's on
the job postings page and we'll send out
an email the last ones - we didn't over
there
and did anyone else higher bar higher
I couldn't talk about Italy he's alright
next piece let's make a big slice pizza
so you all go to big leaps like eat the
bowl all our cases upper case that I'm
different these left feed the pool and
go vote on that the rating of the timer
between excellent good at every port
ever again we all Sparkle I trust we can
all do it I didn't do this lack channel
and as people do use African common are
or ionic it we have job openings areas
and events a channel everything so you
took my half hours at work will see a
link for this black piece you want to be
part of communities most jobs
ask questions it's really any left after
the right house who knows we're right
out of this raise your hand those my
regulars I keep of regulars who didn't
raise their hand
alright so in here so it finally comes
the bar among 17 streets between 15
cents
alright I'm ready you know like this I
think it about shopping
okay if you want to get better than Joey
you know we all have it well we have a
the next three be nuts sorry schedule it
is really amazing you'll never skip over
a month in advance next month it's going
to be jjo later the founder of our
studio show you how to do Pete Marnie
and our that's gonna be February 15 has
to be really really exciting
March is Jennifer Hill men are you she's
what we call him on the young until both
arm she'll be thinking March every other
topic but Julie speaking and then an
eighth row we have an EP out Craig's
been right here the author of the Gran
Sport package talking about we're gonna
talk about Omega so we have February
March and April all planned out February
February 15th the Thursday I know the
Fed will announce it tomorrow we have a
sponsor who is a two-time world
I've been described Emma Skye
actually they just a little bit about
what did it I was doing and co-founder
and it's really exciting to be here it's
really nice jerry- here we're we're here
in Austin Texas under of my associate
yeah we've been on during you know
probably years ago the the goal looking
over the green and sharing collaborating
around and they were very so you know
not simply expanding community of the
assignments analysts engineers all
working to make data work more clouded
more reproducible and more approachable
for a broad audience
pete mcfillin really really awesome
community and really are they awesome
set of tools you know we go out of the
brain data code analysis all the other
in one place and those discussions
around that as well
purely further your work play said
please check out our our sdk you're
essentially used data are all things
working with some of the teachings like
the recent variety Victoria already did
we've got stickers of Hungary almost off
the Catholic mascots Berkeley out so how
do you so come by and see us it is free
for personal use so please sign up grab
your email name Wow laughs if you want
you to sing coming don't get out or
Twitter or anything like that great way
to do it
yeah really how to be here we have many
sponsors but thank you for not sharing
really really do appreciate it it's
really great to see all of you guys have
and we'd love to see all of you guys
using your antenna towers to get one
will do it so thank you thank you
alright short ones only right for our
speaker as they would hear her name plus
PB raysfox data they called them the
time series database founded by an
apologist he also founded the New York
machine learning data machine by highly
recommend you go they are having their
conference
days in the or penalty February if you
want to just comment you just put in the
code in plus 8 and my upon by you know
get a discount to the influx DD
conference I
particularly and speaking at conferences
the 2018 New York our conference is now
open at my registration thank you for
the Assembly's glass thank you for those
of you have not been here before it is
two days and dirty out about all the
tops
lots of food breaks lock through through
via beer we have what Mary's photos and
pizza two of the three demand my
speakers please two of you pass speakers
a starving the best really fun time I
highly recommend we'll check it out if
you've not to support our staff dot NYC
our staff that I might see some of the
speakers are going to include David
Robinson Emily Robinson it's going to
Andrew Gelman and happy women it's going
to be a really great crowd the whole
bunch of people do the whole people I
told him to read well for now go to our
method these are all I can remember
a lot better check out our 720 you only
do one at this camera a totally perfect
the next do we done three times over
pseudonym eyes I'm very proud of okay
not fresh all present I think I got the
order to be black week so I do random
nature are losing our the first winner
is Michael Harmon Michael Harmon yes be
present to win alright then we have mark
Edgar our editor
Hey rather than come on
[Music]
alright okay I can start so I'm sorry
I run the data science team via via is
so at the DM we do smart shared writes
we now operate in New York Chicago DC
Arlington Texas small parts of Austin
London soon parts of England that are
not London
Paris and soon a few other places that I
program who here has used Vienna before
okay who here used uber okay it's like
anymore who here works it over so yeah
so so we we do right now over a million
rides a month just in New York City
we've raised so far we've been around
for about five years so we've been
around for six years we've raised about
three hundred and seventy million
dollars so far we are headed in the the
headquartered in New York City our
engineering Center is in Israel but
between New York and Tel Aviv that's all
of what we do and what we're going to
talk today about is optimized
personalized driver incentives using our
and using some other stuff which all
falls under the open statistical Amita
if you haven't used VI yet at the end of
the presentation we actually have like a
promo code that would give you ten bucks
on your first few rides which most times
during the day would get you to for
rides in Manhattan so that's my intro
Alex who actually did most of the work
is going to do most of the talking
so I'll just let him do his thing all
right hello everybody
yeah so this talk is gonna be about how
we Adia basically assigned promotions to
drivers and a little bit about the
general data science challenges that we
face via and how this specifically fits
in so transportation is undergoing a
transformation so in the beginning of
the 20th century we had most of the
transportation was done by horse-drawn
carriages the middle of the century we
had cards and then towards the end we
just scaled up the card scaled of the
card scaled of the cars until our
infrastructure could no longer really
support them so a part of what via would
like to do is advance this this
progression into into shared electric
and timeless vehicles to solve the
transportation problem in cities so as
you might have mentioned there there are
several parts to this
the when you book and when you book our
ride and via you get assigned a location
where a driver will pick you up and the
app matches you with other riders and
picks an efficient route to get you and
the other riders all to your
destinations so the difference from
something like uber pool or lyft line is
that is not in door-to-door and that
makes the routes that gives us the
routes more freedom and gets people to
their destinations quicker so this is
the sort of crux of the data science
challenges involved in running this type
of service so the first is real-time
routing so how do we get how do we get
all these people in these cars how do we
make them wait the least amount of time
how do we put the most people in the
cars but we without without deviating
too much from each person's each
person's route another part is the
pricing and demand management aspect so
how do we price these vehicles how do
you price these rides in order to keep
keep via competitive but also not break
the bank and finally the inventory
management and supply planning side to
the side that I'm going to talk about
the most so that's how do we get the
right number of drivers out of the road
the right time okay so the the real-time
routing aspect I'm not going to talk too
much about the equations they have up
there from from published paper on this
topic it's it's it's still an open area
of research and our algorithm our
algorithm is more or less proprietary
the pricing and demand management our
goal there is to be different from the
competition in that when you book a ride
it only depends on when and where you're
going so it's not going to depend on
things like search so it just because
there's an event we don't want to price
the ride any higher we're gonna try to
know and keep keep our prices consistent
with the with what the customers expect
and the inventory management and supply
planning piece has several parts and I'm
going to discuss that in a little bit
more detail okay so first of all what if
you think about this question of what
how do we offer rates on the following
day
the usual thing is we just offer drivers
constant rates so we offer them an
hourly rate that's announced ahead of
time but sometimes when the
the from when the competitors are might
be running much better rates we went one
to incentivize the reward drivers the
drivers who still stick with via we went
when our work with them for driving with
us and we want to do that in a smart way
we want to assign promotions to drivers
in a smart way
so the days like when it's raining when
there's a lot of traffic we want to we
want to give drivers a better deal if
you're so we're we're if you think about
this in a different way we're kind of
the
the intermediary is in this exchange we
don't do this of the intermediary as a
liable market so we don't stand between
the customer and the driver at the time
of at the time of purchase but instead
we take on some of the risk that the
driver and the rider might have to face
when they when the rider faces the
decision of choosing an app and on the
driver's side when the driver chooses
whether to drive or not tomorrow so we
don't want the driver to have to think
about the factors that are completely
outside of their control when they make
that decision to drive tomorrow
okay so here's an example of a promotion
that our driver might get so they're
told when to drive them what kind of
rates they're gonna get and this is
going to be announced basically the day
ahead so the question is how do we set
our rates so there there's several parts
of this the key part is that right side
of this diagram which is our quality of
service model and basically what you
need to know is red is bad and blues
good but glue is is basically if it's
too blue it's probably hard to afford so
what we really want is to be in the
white area so we want to pick a
combination of rice for vehicle and for
a given speed that lends us in that
wider area so so you might notice if
there's fees if the traffic is really
bad and the speeds are really low it
doesn't matter how many rides per
vehicle we have we're gonna have bad
service so if the traffic is extremely
dense we can't do anything about of the
service isn't going to be very good a
building and for moderate speeds and
high speeds which is usually the range
that we're in we can see that if we if
we have the right
we assigned the right number of Rights
for vehicle we can actually get good
service so it's gonna the service is
going to depend on the number of rides
per vehicle that we have okay so what do
we need to do this there are there are a
couple of inputs to this so the first is
the demand prediction so in order to
figure out how many rides per vehicle
we're going to have we need to know how
many rides there are going to be so
demands addiction currently India is
done through a series of regressions and
time series models that are combined
with sort of an analysts intuition about
how different this day is and and the
output is then the vanillin centers the
output and traffic is done traffic is
done in a similar way so traffic tends
to be a little bit more stable and the
variations in them tend to be less
predictable and so we build a similar
traffic model around time series and
regressions in order to predict unit
next day's traffic so given those things
we still so given those things we can we
know how we need how many vehicles we
need to get the right
number of the the right quality of
service so we know the speed we
predicted it we know the demand we know
the number of riots so we know we go we
need to do set the right number of
vehicles in order to get the right
quality of service the issue is the
number of vehicles doesn't directly
transform into what promotions we should
have signed to what drivers and that's
really the crux of this how do you the
right drivers the right promotions in
order to get this number of vehicles
that we get from this model how do we
get that number of drivers out there so
this is sort of the the crux of how we
do that so we get that number of drivers
out of our quality of service model we
have a driver promotion response model
so this is a model that predicts for
each driver given some promotion what is
the likelihood of them
on some given shift and then we
combining those things we combined that
a number that target number that we need
and those predictions you know when
you're optimization problem in order to
get in order to basically maximize
engagement for for our drivers so this
all seems pretty simple but the problem
with the ferry's response model is that
there are plenty of unobserved variables
so as you well know ride-sharing is a
highly competitive business and our and
as I'm talking about our competitors
separates in ways that are very hard to
predict so when one day we might have we
might have some promotion we might be
might be cooking up some promotion to
give to our drivers and that same
promotion on a different theme and give
a different number
drivers right because if the competitors
are are giving better rates than a
consonant promotion will give will give
a different number of drivers who will
come in so this is sort of the glimpse
of the machine learning side so now let
me get into the model a little bit more
now so how do we do this so basically
the the data set looks like there's a
single observation for each drivers day
shift so whenever a driver shows up or
it doesn't show up on some day we have
an observation for that and we selected
features for to maximize several metrics
so this is where this started become
feeling a little different from a
standard machine learning problem so in
addition to increasing model performance
which is what you always want to do you
want to have a model that performs well
we were interested in other factors as
well so so for for model performance
things like a drivers history so with
when a driver tended to drive in the
past how much they tended to drive those
things are extremely important for
increasing my local experience on the
other hand in terms of having realistic
sensitivity to promotions we need other
features so we need our model to have
the right responsiveness
in order to be at all useful for
optimization routine but that doesn't
necessarily mean so so this is sort of
if the model were to perform perfectly
well it would have it would have the
right sensitivity to promotion but the
model that has that has better
performance will not necessarily produce
more accurate responsiveness to
promotions it might do that in each of
other features and so what we did was we
basically picked features and feature
sets in accordance with these mostly
these two metrics in mind so we wouldn't
pick features or feature sets that would
reduce either of these two metrics but
and we would include any one that would
increase at least one of them okay so
the first model was a neural network
model so this is sort of a vanilla
neural network it has two hidden layers
it has two output nodes so this diagram
is slightly off there should be two
output nodes there but that's
magenta on network model so it had a
soft max output and what we did is that
we over sampled some of the positive
observations because we saw that that
may be the model at least the time that
we had made the model converge to
reasonable results so that was the
neural network the the second model that
performed really well was X G boost and
so we used the arm limitation and every
boost is basically a model that adds
trees on top of trees and adds up the
results so you might see our first tree
will produce some kind of output then
the second tree will be fit to the
residuals of the first tree and then the
outputs of each of the trees will be
added up the key things that that were
important in terms of tuning this model
were the number of rounds the depth of
the tree and there any one station
parameters and between those between
those hyper parameters we could we could
iterate on those type of parameters in
order to in order to gather the right
performance both in terms of traditional
model performance and in terms of
sensitivity to sensitivity to promotions
okay so what are some of the key
problems that we faced here so the first
thing good enough is not just about
for months so we can't call it a day
because of that model performance the
second thing is we have to be sensitive
to promotions and I'll go over in a
little bit of both that means and a
third thing is a model has to be more or
less accurate in aggregate not just for
individual drivers so when we add up the
drivers we have to get the right number
we can just get there a more or less
accurate predictions for each individual
driver and those two things don't
necessarily translate one-to-one to each
other because the year is for each
individual driver might be correlated
with each other and so that means the
sum can be the sum can be systematically
influenced if the if the errors
correlated like that so let's go over an
example here so this is an example of
where model has is actually a better
reflection of reality so if you were to
calculate what happens
[Laughter]
these are basically raised these are
predictions for a lot of model too and
what actually
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
look at the margins so the proportion of
people who drove was actually around
0.17 but the neural network
overestimated the number of different
who's gonna wish driver is more likely
to show up but that's not all we cared
about we cared about the aggregates as
well right so if we were to the words of
some Z's these numbers about the news
calibrated numbers would be inaccurate
so our total would just be way too high
but so because we're interested in that
it's not good enough to have this kind
of model and so we think this was caused
by the over sampling that we did when we
fill the neural network so this is no
surprise the model was actually trained
on more observations of drivers driving
than there actually were so it was more
likely to predict in a new data set that
this would be the case so what we needed
to do is we needed to calibrate it so we
just put another another fully connected
layer on it and basically made a much
smaller model of that math essentially
the red line to that dashed line
and so after doing that what happened
was we got essentially the same
percentage for both models and we got we
got essentially the
calibration German you can see some of
these deviations but actually he looked
at any one of these deviations it's a
very small sample size so this
calibration the model was was making
well care calibrated prediction so that
means when it was when it was saying
there was a point one percent chance for
drivers for whom was saying there was a
point one percent chance of driving
there was actually a point one percent
chance of driving okay so here is here
are the results for model sensitivity so
this is averaged across a couple of
weeks drivers sort of selected group of
drivers that we were estimating this
model on their likelihood to drive and
so you can see you can see the neural
network and if used are both sensitive
to promotions so both of them think that
you give people more money they're more
likely to drive no surprise there but
you might also notice that extra whose
sensitivity was much higher and in
comparing those two experimental studies
that we ran so where we randomly
assigned drivers different promotions we
see that both of XG boost and more
accurately reflected that data now we
couldn't just drink train the models on
the data from these
because we had much fewer drivers in
there across a much smaller set of days
so the model wouldn't produce a good
enough outcome but if we just compare
the results of the experiment to the
sensitivity of the model we see that
extra boost does more accurate
reflection okay and so these are this is
aggregate performance so we have we have
extra boost again in blue and we have
the neural network in red and this
middle line here is basically when
training ended and we cross validated on
the fly to your right on the side of the
flat to your right and what you can see
is in aggregate has water residual seems
to it seems to her on the negative side
it seems to underestimate
so that made our call pretty easy
and while the both of the models had
similar similar performance in terms of
traditional metrics and one of them had
features that sort of made sense to us
it reflected and reflected reality the
outputs reflected the reality that we
saw in in experiments and the reality
that we expected so finally we've got
all that input we gathered the input
from the model in such a way as to
minimize the total expected cost and so
one of the inputs into the total
expected cost is of course the
likelihood of the specific driver
driving but it was constrained to give
the driver only one promotion and we
needed to get that right number of
drivers in the road so if you might
remember from the earlier part of the
presentation our quality of service
model will tell us how many drivers meet
on the road but now we're gonna try to
optimize your order together so it's
important to note that the optimization
was we never take away money from
drivers so this is just a way of
assigning additional promotions on top
of where the drivers might expect so
this model isn't used in any way to to
reduce paid of any of the drivers it
only adds it only adds
on top of their base rates okay so
here's here's how the optimization works
so we're gonna try we're gonna try to
find a parent that has a length of P
times D so the number of promotions
times the number of drivers so assume
for a second we have four drivers of the
three promotions we're going to have
vector of length length 12 and so the
first three elements are gonna indicate
which promotion driver one is going to
get so this might mean that driver one
will get the second promotion this might
mean that driver two will get the third
promotion so you can see how this vector
sort of reflects the assignments of the
promotions to the drivers we're gonna
subject that we're gonna subject that
that vector to the following constraints
so the first constraint is the first
driver has to get exactly one promotion
so that means when we multiply this
vector by our driver promotion and
that's the constraint will enforce and
so we're anxious with these vectors of
constraints constraint right so the next
the next three constraints we'll just
say for each of these drivers we can
only get
each of these rows by our by our simple
machine you have to get exactly one the
next constraint is that the total number
of expected drivers must be greater than
or equal to some number so when we fill
in this this row with are the outputs
from our machine learning model so we're
gonna run the machine learning model on
several hypothetical scenarios so we're
gonna run them what if we tomorrow we
gave all the drivers this promotion what
if we gave them motion - what if we gave
them promotion three so for each driver
we're going to get as many promotions as
we want and then we'll line them up in
this vector that's going to be D times Q
law okay so finally we're gonna yeah
so in order to do this right that's a
good point the way that we actually is
significant meaning of promotion one
might be the driver not receiving a
promotion at all so it sort of just
conceptually a type of promotion yeah I
mean they have some of the drivers when
I receive promotions but do we actually
so when we actually do this we try to be
really careful in terms of in terms of
the driver experience so so in no way
will be will any driver receive no
promotion if they did not receive a
promotion in the previous day so we
actually do have an additional
constraint in here that that says if you
didn't receive a promotion yesterday you
have to receive a promotion today so
even if it's a smaller motion you have
to receive some promotion that's larger
than your base pay okay so what we're
gonna do is try to minimize this
expected cost this expected cost vector
and that consists of those same numbers
that we saw before so the predicted life
is
we got out of work machine learning
model and we're gonna multiply that by
the cost if that driver shows up so
conditional in that are showing up how
much would we pay them get with this
worth of promotion we offered them so
busy in this example promotion one will
cost one promotion too will cost two and
promotion three equal cost three so
we're going to do is we're gonna sell
that whole sum of those products and
we're gonna get some number out of it
and we're gonna try to we're gonna we're
going to take an argument number
okay switch here are some examples this
is an example of a solution that doesn't
work so this solution first of design
the first and the third promotion to the
first drivers who won't satisfy the
first constraint Priority One promotion
second of all it gives driver three no
emotions at all so that won't satisfy
that drivers constraint and finally when
we add up these when we add up the
selected languages to try the sum is
going to be less than two so we were not
the expected number
the road is not right so that emotion
won't work this is a promotion that
doesn't work so we give each promotion
each driver exactly that doesn't work we
do each driver you that like one
promotion and our expected number of
drivers on the road is going to be
actually exactly two so the point when I
was 25 plus point I am was point one
we're going to get two so that that
solves our that solves all of our
constraints and it outputs a cost so if
this is how we assign the promotion's
this is the cost as we get but if you
look at these numbers this is pretty
clearly not the optimal solution so for
example driver to here not very
sensitive
at all and they got the biggest one so
this might not be the best and in fact
these are the promotions that we assign
me we get a lower total box as this the
solution would be preferable so what
this optimization routine does is it
cycles through these different possible
driver assignments and in an intelligent
way and picks the one that satisfies all
the constraints but minimizes the clock
the total expected okay and he'd be test
drivers into this scheme and some
drivers the way that we would normally
assign them without taking into account
individual characteristics and so one
thing that we saw is we saw a lower cost
for our drivers for our drivers in the
optimization condition but possibly more
importantly as we saw a very similar
level of engagement so what we didn't
see is drivers being unhappy with this
optimization scheme what we didn't see
is
drivers dropping out or over a long run
sir we didn't see lower levels of
engagement
we're scaling it up currently so here's
some here's some things that were sort
of lessons for me the first project of
this has done some machine learning and
so there are some things that are not
surprisingly so there is there
difficulties in using in not just being
able to say what and maximize fit so
what are some of these difficulties well
if you come up with some of these
metrics we have it or we have our
aggregate performance and we have our
model sensitivity so those when you have
several metrics you can't just maximize
one thing so that means you to come up
with some trade-off of how to combine
traditional and non-traditional metrics
so in our case this wasn't super
difficult because the models that we
ended up with the models that performed
really well one of the first of all in
terms of traditional performance they
were similar but in terms of the in
terms of the non-traditional performance
there they were one of them was clearly
better than the other so we didn't
really have to think about how we might
have to trade those off or how we have
to trade those off and the second thing
is if you have if you have this sort of
this idea of reasonable output you have
to be able to quantify it so you can you
can't say that you just want you want
the model to to work the way you expect
it so you have to think really hard
about what that means another lesson was
that
in terms of just increasing increasing
the models performance one of the best
predictors was previous behavior so we
have a ton of features that we tried a
ton of Future groups the best thing for
predicting a person's behavior in the
future is their behavior at that so the
more ways that you can kind of quantify
what it means what there we get here in
the past means if you're gonna try to
predict the person's behaviors that
would be really useful yeah
getting the right sensitivity to the
promotion that was one of the key things
is being able to accurately describe the
promotion history or a given driver so
what promotions did the driver get in
the past obviously promotion some
promotion will be different for a driver
who has gotten better promotions or
promotions they obviously compared the
promotions to what they've gotten in the
past yeah that was a key part yeah
right so the in terms of the long-term
we we have this for about for about
three months and over that term but we
compared where the people on the two
groups and we didn't see we didn't see a
difference at any differences in terms
of engagement that is your question yeah
that's a good question I mean even if
drivers communicate and influence I know
we do know that they communicate we also
know that they so the way that are
traditionally operates in terms of
assigning drivers promotions is there
are certain differently we will give
different vehicles different promotions
and that's that's not news to the
drivers so so so some I think they know
that there's some individualization
going on and so anything is an increase
in individualization probably not be a
big big change there yeah
you mean in terms of the t-shirts or in
terms of the yes so so we could hope
that the because the model that we used
was a tree based model it would be able
to sort of differentiate groups like
that and hopefully on top of that be
able to differentiate within groups even
so because there are these consecutive
splits then the first didn't splits the
whole thing and then if it's the
residuals so hopefully will not only be
able to capture these guys are bigger
than these guys also differences within
those distributions yeah
right right right yeah I mean that's a
really good question I bet there there
are people who in our company who asked
those kinds of questions and answer them
I guess that was not that was not within
the scope of what I did yeah
strange so those things were actually
days off on those days when the day was
especially when we anticipated that they
had that was gonna be a day that
other days to do such as July fourth
being the Columbus Day maybe a snowstorm
we actually didn't run the optimization
at all because it's probably different
things are in play yeah
the pocket terms of their writer those
houses in one's drivers rating down the
road
all right yeah but that seems like a
really good really good yeah so don't
make that assumption we have tried sort
of assessing the degree to which drivers
actually know what's going on and we
know we know that we know that so most
drivers will look at them we also know
that it's not all drivers it's yeah like
some drivers hopefully this is well
that's in some way be able to get it
back so a driver who doesn't even care
about promotions doesn't make sense the
sound
[Music]
so the promotions are mostly delivered
what kind of service yes I mean we do we
do ask drivers like what like why why do
you drive how much they drive over here
what do you like about data like stuff
like that we do ask that we can't ever
ask a huge scale so we can't apply that
to all our drivers yeah but that could
be it could be a good thing to include
as well so let me go through a couple
more slides and in terms of the modeling
to me was understanding that there are
trade-offs between complex models more
complex models and more simple models so
very early on we've sort of abandoned
the idea of just using a linear
regression because
was vastly underperforming compared to
other other models that we have at play
the downside of abandoning abandoning
linear regression was that one of those
nice features is that it tells you
confidence intervals for your
observations and that would have been
really nice to have in terms of being
able to have a confidence interval
around her stuff we would also be able
to in addition to knowing the
uncertainty in terms of the drivers
predictions we will be able to assess
the correlations between the different
observations now one way of resolving
that problem is bootstrapping whatever
model it is that you have and with extra
boost that's hard but realistic so you
can rerun actually boosts many many
times over a long period and see what
kinds of results you get with the neural
network it's essentially impossible
because the it already takes a
significant amount of time just to train
at once so some things some features of
more complicated that more complicated
models lack can actually be really
useful another thing is that no time
calibration so as your model becomes as
you need to do more custom things to
make your model fit you need to also
think about
affects that those custom things have on
traditional properties of miles that you
just expect your statistical models that
you kind of expect your model to be well
calibrated well that's not necessarily
true if you did you did some custom
things to me get converge faster so so
it's not when when when it's possible
it's nice to stay within to pick a more
simple another thing is in terms of
ramping up our use of this kind of
approach one of the key things was in
being able to integrate analysts into
this process so for a while I'll just be
looking at a lot of intermediary plots
so what what is the what is the model
produced what is the optimization
produce what are the actual assignments
of the promotion any of this looks
reasonable so what why is this the case
well if you if you assign the if you
assign promotions in a really really
dumb way on a really important day that
can mean that
yeah you know one-third less drivers on
the road and that could mean that your
management can say no we're not doing
this anymore like this is this price is
just not worth it you can't have any
catastrophic days so being able to have
sort of digestible information about
about how what the model was producing
what the model was doing and different
steps was really important in terms of
keeping this writing and I have to say
like they were they're worth days in
which the somewhere in the data pipeline
we had above there was a change in the
underlying data set if I haven't been a
if there weren't visuals of what the
model was doing what would happen is we
would get ridiculous outputs so it's
important to check especially while
you're in the development stage okay so
that's that's our little code and I'll
take more questions now
so we just trying forever and of course
didn't do quite the job is there is
there way for this to work on their own
networks and
do you think there is a way somehow
they probably could like I can tell you
that I tried to figure out how it works
and I am the data scientist and it was
very difficult but I mean maybe boiled
by like a lot of trial and error and
like some sort of you know randomly
changing their behavior they haven't
kept really good track of what they were
doing they can eventually converge on it
yeah but it I don't think it's
straightforward yeah well so the problem
is like you can't the problem is you
can't make repeated draws into the model
on the same given the same other
conditions so you can't like hold one
feature constant and make repeated draws
for yourself like don't know any way you
can do it is so you wouldn't need to
like all your driver buddies to get
together and like require all of their
stuff and then somehow back like figure
out what is the difference between you
and them and do it that way but that
would only work on that specific day
because the features of the day also
influence having the different designs
to different drivers hardly but you need
you still need to resample right yeah we
think you they can resample they can
only be themselves
yeah
so the neural network was it was mostly
in Python I think the the implementation
was intensive one would just run the
data through it as it was going extra
boost actually has a really nice
distributed implementation which I
didn't use I used so whatever I ended up
doing is kind of a hacky way around it I
ended up importing the data and then
sampling it to figure out what is the so
if I use X amount more data what is the
change in prediction and then I used
like said this is the cutoff like I need
any more data it doesn't improve the
prediction with this number of features
and call it a day
yeah where do we get the traffic
information from well and we know how
our cars are driving and they're driving
all over the city yeah yeah I mean
that's the only part of traffic that
we're concerned with like we're not
concerned with the traffic in the city
in general we're just concerned with
traffic how it influences our drivers
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah just for the
smile yeah
so we're actually still ramping it up
where now I don't think so okay I have
no point is this going to be applied to
100 percent of drivers because with what
happens if we apply it down hundred
percent of drivers as we no longer have
a training set because everyone is
assigned promotion this way and so we
always need to lead people out but yeah
this isn't right
yes yes there are people who do this
yeah they don't do it on an individual
basis they do done like a aggregate
basis yeah yeah
right now we're only doing this in New
York it's by far the biggest market
there's there's way more data I'm not I
don't even know if there's enough data
in the other cities to be able to run it
right now yeah yeah
what was the initial sort of reason for
doing this yeah so we wanted to we
wanted to be able to offer we wanted to
be able to offer and drivers better
promotions I think that's really at the
core of this and be able to there's
different types of promotions it's not
just about the amount of money so it
basically would be just this promotion
being this driver happy how can we give
the driver the promotion that influences
them in the best way yeah
yeah yeah so we had just been up a
pretty big cluster in order to be able
to do this but it's pretty cheap on
Amazon to do it over time the size of
the data I don't know we were I think in
the end they were just under too much a
feature or something like that and they
were I think it was so in terms of the
data pipeline there were a bunch of it
so they were there's a bunch of this
processing that we couldn't do in memory
so we tried to find more or less clever
ways to be able to read it in piece wise
and then do the analysis that way
fortunately it's not will we haven't
implemented of streaming architecture
for this project yeah yeah
you know the the header parameters are
really important so that the ones before
where extra boost I was setting those
hyper parameters and refitting tomahto
in a way that so there was a cross
foundation that asked about the
traditional and non-traditional measures
of fit and you look at them and try to
find a point where you're really good at
the non-traditional ones but you're also
not really trading off you're not really
trading off the traditional measure of
fit for the neural network I think
because it takes so long to run the the
hyper parameters were only changed two
or three times and we did not look at
other measures of fit for the neural
network it was it was just to maximize
performance yeah yeah Wow
you mean poorly the service of you or
where this project
no just about with how much time the
drivers spend on we tell them where to
go so as long as they're showing up its
yeah yeah
over time so in terms so so what I tried
to do for the EB test was not refit the
model during the B test and just fitted
the one time and then say how it was
perform going forward so that's what
that's how that was doing since then I
have we fit the model there's no right
now there's no automated way like this
happens at certain intervals but I also
haven't seen sort of see changes in
perfectly encrust validated performance
so but again would you need to come up
with like a regular schedule somehow
figure out
[Music]
no the project service is how linking
whether the car isn't able to get there
on time and whether we're able to serve
the service like whatever we were able
to serve as a right on time and whether
we're able to serve as a right at all
that's why
right I guess yes some people suggested
looking at star rating ticking that's a
good that's a good way to go in terms of
assessing that to more
do you for drivers yeah yes so they get
they get readings then go feedback
we like a promotion because we have yeah
yeah definitely
yeah that's a figuring on the right ones
definitely sort of being targeted
there's a lot of one more have so many
questions and there's no one that okay I
will call it a day thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]